hi michelle hi jamie hi hi toronto
um i have to tell you this is one of the
best experiences i've ever had
in a theater watching this movie was
just the most entertaining thing of all
time jamie you've worked on some of the
best movies you have said that this was
a career highlight for you what made
this experience so memorable
michelle yo
um honestly i'm not and i you know look
let's just pretend she's not here
because then it just becomes like this
weird thing where i say nice things
about her she says nice things about me
the truth of the matter is she was the
entire reason i said yes i the script i
didn't really understand i just said yes
when they said it was her i said yes it
didn't matter to me because
i don't get that opportunity we're not
going to get a chance you know unless
somebody writes us a funny buddy comedy
um
this was going to be my chance to work
with her and for me that was a great
experience and a highlight for me
because
i went in not knowing anything about any
of it and you know i became not only
friends but then also just like i was
her student and you know i i did a
martial arts movie i showed you you know
what i'm saying like i did a martial
arts movie with michelle yeah
like it's cray-cray to me so i'm just
really happy and i'm about to make love
with her i know and hold her and and
feel her and be undressed by her by her
feet um for me it was just a career
highlight it was brave and uh bold and
uh unexpectedly
delicious
and
i'm just thrilled to be a part of it
oh my goodness i love that michelle so
many expressions what's your take on
that by god i i'm sure somebody heard
you okay somebody has to write us a
buddy movie together
they can see the chemistry that we have
off camera forget about just being on
camera it's like
being with jamie was so empowering
because she's fearless there's a woman
not just the most amazing talent
but
big heart
most generous human being big tummy
big heart big tummy ah yeah oh my god
buddha belly totally buddha belly every
day when i go to work i'm like come here
to mama please i have to drop that
buddha belly
it was like love at first sight
i cannot oh my gosh
anybody else doing that deidre and
carried it off with such
heart and sincerity i think that was the
core of our movie as well
all the relationships were so real
you know with the husband and wife key
my god what an amazing talent he is
after 20 years he's come back and what a
way to come back he is just beautiful
and then with stephanie the mother and
daughter relationship in whatever
universe we were looking for each other
and we found each other and we never
gave up on each other she's
just a spectacular talented actress and
james hong come on
oh my god the sketch very good
i can understand why you know this was
such a special movie you know this movie
really made us question if we're really
in the multiverse what do you think your
other job would be in another universe
jamie have you thought about that
let me say this everybody who's been
ever near me knows that i can't sing
so for me
being able to stand up on a stage and
sing a song
i like i just watched the other day
bradley um cooper and gaga do their duet
at the oscars
i just don't know what that would feel
like to be able to do that and so for me
if i could choose a universe i would do
that
i love that and i got i i'm getting the
wrap of jimmy i want to ask you really
quickly john travolta adopting mac and
cheese what was your reaction come on
you know what honestly
i it was the last thing i thought would
happen
uh i finished my gig i got in the car i
got um i was
out of the building in my pajamas before
we left the parking lot and all of a
sudden somebody sent me a picture of
john holding the dog backstage i thought
oh that's so cute
and how wonderful for mac and cheese to
give mac and cheese a little more
visibility and then the next day i
called the shelter and we were talking
and chad atkins who owns the shelter
said
by the way john's adopting
mac and cheese i was like wait what
so
first of all just so you know i haven't
seen john in a long time
and
i love him
and so to run into him three times
backstage that night three times we
found ourselves
face to face in that green room it just
really felt like a perfect
ending to the whole experience for me is
that an old friend adopted that
beautiful little dog
i love that well listen uh this is a
career highlight for me i'm not even
kidding i told everyone i know i was
interviewing both of you ladies the fact
that you're both together you're my
favorite actresses so thank you so much
thank you thank you
bye guys